i remember sal and richard telling me
that out of all the whack pack that come
into their studio the one person that
they wouldn't allow in because he
smelled so bad was jeff for anybody out
there who doesn't know who jeff the
vomit guy is he's a self-proclaimed
vomit lover he spends his days looking
for women to vomit on them if richard is
disgusted by jeff the vomit guy that's
pretty bad because richard's pretty
[ __ ] disgusting
oh my god it is i can't even put into
words howard the smell
from him
it is it's not just a stink
it is like an otherworldly like another
dimension smell like something that
immediately makes you want to
run like 20 miles away it's like walking
death it is
i've smelled i grew up on a farm like a
cow would die across the street from my
parents house and they'd just get left
there into for weeks until the dead
animals
and jeff is worse i'm sorry jeff you're
listening
i mean jeff's nice i got nothing against
him but for me to say that somebody
smells bad it is bad and we sal and i
put our foot down we said okay we can't
record with jeff we got no problem with
beetlejuice bigfoot other people that
are well you know
you said eric and beetlejuice have the
worst breath ever but jeff is worse yes
absolutely and beetle's breath is so bad
that we used to there's these foam
microphone covers that we use and like
beetle's breath like stuck around on
these foam microphone covers for days
after we record with him and we put one
in a glass jar as an experiment and
smelled it like a year later and you
could still smell beetle's breath in the
glass jar it's literally still in our
studio back in new york but jeff jeff
takes the cake jeff's the only guy in
show history that you would not record
with in your studio yeah we had to put
our foot down we were like hey listen
we're team players we'll do anything
we'll record with anybody but jeff we
just can't do it we can't do is that why
years ago we interviewed jeff on a park
bench outside the building for over an
hour that's exactly why like he wasn't
even like allowed up at the office
richard has [ __ ] his pants in the office
i mean it's uh you know these are these
are hardcore gross guys and they're
grossed out by jeff the vomit guy
unbelievable
i love vomiting
women vomit
i love it